[Music]
the trailer ending scenes for China
Japan and the first one for Global
audiences of gxk the new Empire have
three different ending scenes let's do a
short cute and sweet explanation for
each one of them shall we so the latest
one the Chinese trailer ending shows
Kong with a beast glove which is a
mechanical contraption that is being
developed by Monarch to assist Kong in
case of an injury which he would
eventually have when Kong fights the
scar King in the hollow Earth and loses
his eggs so this would be an upgrade
from the Titan storm breaker that a
through the Titan Infinity Gauntlet this
Beast glove I guess they're going full
endgame on this one Dan Steven's
character would be the one that would
develop the blueprint for the this
mechanical Contraption given that he is
a Titan veterinarian or something like
that and maybe it will be powered by The
Hollow Earth
[Music]
Energy the Japanese trailer ending shows
Godzilla inside the Coliseum in Rome and
this would be in the beginning of the
movie well the earlier scenes where he
would rest in that ancient Stadium after
fighting an unknown or more specifically
an unspecified arachnet Titan which
could be a new one or an older kotm
Titan like Siller Godzilla could
theoretically fit inside the coliseum in
a fetal position but the tail would
break the structure and the ruins inside
of it would become dust so there goes
ancient Roman
history is that a mini
cone the global trailer of course shows
suko or otherwise known as the mini Kong
and he would be in the hollow Earth
maybe trying to Signal a warning to the
monar team that something has gone wrong
with gong suko here is a red ape much
like the scar King and he is still a
small kid in terms of Titan growth and
development yet he is already bigger
than the juvenile Kong of Skull Island
in
1973 the one which was seen in the 2017
Skull Island movie so that's all we have
for now now if you like this video and
watch this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other
monsterverse content many other videos
we might just have things you haven't
seen before like subscribe and we'll see
you in the next one take care
[Music]
fam
good
[Music]
is that a mini
Kong